we're now going to learn a little bit
about gravity and just so you know
gravity is something that especially in
introductory physics or even reasonably
advanced physics we can learn how to
calculate it we can learn how to realize
what are the important variables in it
but it's something that's that's really
not well understood even once you learn
general relativity if you if you do get
there I have to say you know you can
kind of say oh well it's you know the
warping of space-time and all this but
it's hard to get an intuition of why two
objects just by a you know just because
they have this thing called mass they
are attracted to each other it's it's
really at least to me a little bit
mystical but with that said let's let's
learn to detect deal with gravity and
we'll do that learning Newton's law of
gravity gravity and this works for most
purposes so Newton's law of gravity says
that the force between two masses and
that's the gravitational force is equal
to the gravitational constant G times
the mass of the first object times the
mass of the second object divided by the
distance between the two objects squared
so that's simple enough so let's see
let's play around with this and and see
if we can get some results that look
reasonably familiar to us so let's use
this formula to figure out what the
acceleration at the surface the
gravitational acceleration is at the
surface of the earth so let's draw the
earth just so we we know what we're
talking about so that's my earth and
let's say we want to figure out the
gravitational acceleration on Sal that's
me
that's Sal and so how do we how do we
apply this equation to figure out how
how much I am accelerating down towards
these the center of Earth or the Earth's
center of mass let's say the force is
equal to so what's this big G thing the
G is the gravitational universal
gravitational constant although I'm not
as far as I know and I'm not an expert
on this I actually think it it can its
measurement can change it's not truly
truly a constant or I guess when you you
know on different scales it can be a
little bit different but for our
purposes
it is a constant and the constant in
most physical classes is this six point
six seven times 10 to the negative 11th
meters cubed per kilogram second squared
I know these units are crazy but all you
have to realize is these are just the
units needed that when you multiply it
times a mass and a mass divided by a
distance squared you get Newtons or
kilogram meters per second squared so we
won't worry so much about the unit's
right now just you know realize that you
have to work with meters and kilograms
and seconds so let's just write that
number down so let's say I'll change
colors to keep it interesting six point
six seven times ten to the negative 11
and we want to know the acceleration on
Sal so it would be so M 1 is the mass of
Sal and I don't feel like revealing my
mass in this video so I'll just leave it
as a variable and then what's the mass -
it's the mass of Earth and I wrote that
here I looked it up on Wikipedia this is
the mass of Earth so I multiplied times
the mass of Earth times 5.9 seven times
10 to the 24 kilograms weighs a little
bit
not weighs is a little bit more massive
than Sal divided by the distance squared
now you might say well what's the
distance between someone standing on the
earth and the earth well it's zero
because they're touching the Earth but
it's important to realize that the
distance between the two objects
especially when we're talking about the
universal law of gravitation is the
distance between their center of masses
for all general purposes my center of
mass you know maybe it's like three feet
above the ground because I'm not that
tall it's probably a little bit lower
than that actually anyway my center of
mass might be three feet above the
ground and whereas Earth's center of
mass what's at the center of Earth so we
have to know the radius of Earth right
so the radius of Earth is I've also
looked it up on Wikipedia 6,371
kilometers so how many meters is that so
it's six million meters right and then
you know the extra meter to get to my
center of mass we could ignore from now
because it would be zero zero one so
we'll ignore that for now so it's six
and I'll write it in scientific notation
since everything else is in scientific
notation six point three seven one times
ten to the sixth meters right 6,000
kilometers is sick
million meters so let's write that down
so the distance is going to be six point
three seven times ten to the sixth
meters and we had a square that remember
it's a distance squared so let's let's
see if we can simplify this a little bit
let's uh let's well just multiply those
top numbers first so force is equal to
let's bring the variable out mass of Sal
times let's do this top part so we have
six point six seven times five point
nine seven times five point nine seven
is equal to thirty nine point eight to
thirty nine point eight two I just
multiply this times this and after
multiply the tens so ten to the negative
11 times 10 to the negative
twenty-fourth we can just add the
exponents to the same base so what's 24
minus eleven is ten to the thirteenth
right and then what is the denominator
look like it's going to be the six point
three seven squared times ten to the six
squared well 10 does it so it's going to
be whatever this is going to be like 37
or something times what's ten to the
sixth squared it's 10 to the twelfth
right 10 to the twelfth so let's figure
out what six point three seven squared
is this little calculator I have doesn't
have squared so I've to six point three
seven so it's forty point five eight
forty point five eight and so
simplifying it that's the force is equal
to the mass of Sal times let's divide
thirty nine thirty nine point eight two
divided by forty point five eight is
equal to nine point eight one nine point
eight one that's just this divided by
this and then ten to the 30
/ 10 to the 12 is what I'll actually
know this is a 9.81 sorry it's 0.98 one
0.98 1 and then 10 to the 13 divided by
10 to the 12 is just 10 right 10 to the
first times 10 so it's point 9 8 1 times
10 well so the force is equal to 9 point
8 1 times the mass of Sal and where does
this guy how can we figure out the
acceleration right now
well acceleration force is just mass
times acceleration right so that's also
going to just be equal to the
acceleration of gravity that's that's
that's suppose to be a small G there
times the mass of Sal right so we know
the gravitational force is 9.81 times
the mass of Sal and we also know that
that's the same thing as the
acceleration of gravity times the mass
of Sal we can divide both sides by the
mass of Sal we have the acceleration of
gravity and if we use the unit's the
whole way you would have seen that it is
kilograms meters per second squared and
we have just shown that at least based
on the numbers of that they've given in
Wikipedia the the the acceleration of
gravity on the surface of the earth is
almost exactly what we've been using and
all the projectile motion problems it's
9.8 meters per second squared that's
exciting
let's do another quick problem with
gravity because I got two minutes let's
say let's say I have there's another
planet to call the planet small earth
and let's say you know the radius of
small earth radius of small earth is
equal to 1/2 the radius of Earth and the
mass of small earth is equal to 1/2 the
mass of Earth so what's what's the
gravity
what's what's the pull of gravity on any
object say the same object on this how
much smaller would it be on this planet
well actually let me save that to the
next video because I hate being rushed
so I'll see you soon